Speaker 1: I think and and I hope that this will
be interesting to you. I've spoken before on
the show about what I call these unsubscribed
trolls. These are people who loudly tell me,
sometimes for years I was just about to become
a paid member. I was just about to do it. But
then you said this, and now I'm never giving you
a penny or I have been a subscriber for years, but
now I'm canceling because you said the wrong thing
or whatever. I have one of these examples for you,
and it's kind of evolved over several months. Over
the weekend, an email came in from someone named
Yulia who said, I'm canceling and I'm canceling
David because you were not transphobic enough. Now
those are my words, not their words, and I looked
up their email history. This is why we keep it.
And hilariously, they've been emailing me for
six months, and it's always about how I'm not
transphobic enough. I need to be more transphobic.
And it started with I was about to give you money,
but I'm not. And now it's I'm canceling because
you're not transphobic. This is fascinating. So
let's start with the first email. This one's from
early October, where Yulia said, Hey David, I've
been watching your YouTube channel for some time.
I was thinking about joining to contribute money,
but there is one thing that has kept me from
it. You see the most attractive thing about
your channel. For me, I'm a molecular biologist
as you frame your narrative around science,
including the vaccine debates. But there was
one thing that turned me off. There was one show
in which you talked about trans people saying
something that everyone, everybody on the
left tends to say transwomen are women. Now is
virtually any biologists will tell you sex is real
and cannot be changed by current scientific
methods. In my opinion, if you're all about
science, saying that transwomen are women
is grossly inaccurate. It's true to say
transwomen are transwomen, but not women.
You're saying that they are women because
they identify as women or whatever is something
that sounded hypocritical to me as a biologist.
I would join and support your channel, I guess,
if you stayed more accurate to science because
as a scientist, I've been looking for a leftist
who would be true to science guys. Is is Julia,
a scientist? I think it was only mentioned
five times in this email. So first of all,
I have never denied that biological sex exists. I
have never claimed that current scientific methods
chromosomally change a man to a woman
or a woman to a man. But I have said
that for the purposes of society and how I will
deal with people. It makes no difference to me
whether a woman is biologically
female or not, if that is how they are
living their life and want to be seen. OK, so
anyway, you get the point that was in October,
November, Yulia writes in again and says, How
are you left different from Trumpists? David,
I appreciate your show. But this recent question
about transgender ism has caught my attention.
Now, remember, they were about to subscribe in
October and didn't. They're still watching, though
I think you would be doing a disservice to
yourself into the community if you continue
to blindly follow the left propaganda about
transgender ism. I know, I know inclusivity. So
should we, for the sake of inclusivity, teach
creation science in schools? Your show's most
prominent feature is you position yourself as
true to the facts. It is what I and most of
your audience, I suppose like about you. This is
not the first time Yulia speaks for my audience,
and Yulia goes on to say, So tell me when a male
person says, I feel I am a woman. Therefore,
it is true and you believe him and insist on
everyone calling this male person a female.
How is this different from people saying Trump won
when he didn't? How is this not a delusion? The
same way, Trumpists think Trump won again? This
is not tailored to the things I have said on the
show. But they are continuing to slam me. And then
the final straw guy and listen. Six seven months
of being displeased with what I say and continuing
to watch, Yulia has had enough. Why unsubscribe,
David? I might not be significant for you. I'm
just a biological scientist, but I have to say
I am unsubscribing and perhaps many other people
will follow again speaking for everybody else.
The reason is I was under the impression you were
a nonpartisan, objective reality check science
channel. You betrayed me. When you talk about
so-called trans people, you evoke no statistics,
you evoke no scientific argument. All you said
was just in agreement with YouTube policy. I wish
said it out loud, I am saying this because
this is in agreement with YouTube policy,
but you didn't say that. Guys, I don't know
what she's talking about. I have no idea.
Anyway, Julia says I cannot recommend you or
your channel to anyone I know because you lack
integrity. I am very sorry. You do not
deserve a place in my media stream and I am
a scientist. You are not about science. I'm trying
to. I almost forgot between emails two and three
that Yulia is a scientist. But now I remember
anyway, I don't even know that I've said most
of the stuff she's referring to. The issue of
trans people doesn't come up a ton on this show.
But you know what? Good riddance, Yulia.
Good riddance. I was never going to be the
trans phobe that you wanted me to be, so
I'm sorry to see you go, but not really.
And hopefully this means no more emails. That's
another really funny thing. Sometimes people
are like, I haven't been subscribed for three
years, but I'm going to email you every week
with some critique of what you said. I'm fine
for you to unsubscribe, but please stop the
email. So that's a little peek behind the curtain
at the stuff we're dealing with on a daily basis.